hey china let's talk about china what
happened with china go to page seven
uh with china so our uh this is uh
china expanding its nuclear capability
scientists say bbc story china is
expanding its capacity to store and
launch nuclear missiles you assigned to
say
satellite images from jinjang province
and the west of the
country suggest that it's building a
nuclear missile so uh
silo field it is the second new silo
field
reported to be under construction
western china last two months the site
could house
about 110 silos which are underground
facilities used for storing and
launching missiles in 2020 china had a
nuclear stockpile
of more than 200 warheads and was aiming
to at least
double this amount the pentagon says the
u.s has approximately 3 800
warheads and in a propaganda video china
threatens to nuke japan after japan vows
to defend taiwan in a now deleted
propaganda video china threatens to nuke
japan following comments made by
japanese leaders vowing to defend taiwan
from chinese invasion the nearly six
minute video
which was posted to the chinese
communist party sanctioned channel
jigua featured images and videos of
chinese war machines such as tanks and
fighter jets edited into pictures of a
devastated 1940s japan following the
world war ii u.s nuclear strikes
on hiroshima and nagasaki the video
references japan's defeat in world war
ii before promising full-scale war
against the only country to have ever
been nuked
the video also said there will be no
peace
talks tom how much do you love china
what um
well first of all whenever you talk
about china you have to talk about
russia because china and russia are now
really intertwined and russia has leaned
over that way
i mean china just had a meeting with the
taliban leaders of afghanistan yesterday
i don't know if you saw that or not
want to see that the video i mean
they've been supplying weapons to them
for 20 years
did you actually see that i did not see
that i did not see that video the
foreign minister of china yesterday met
with
the uh afghani taliban leader yesterday
there you go well here's what's going on
here
people need to understand that
taiwan is a
global semiconductor and market share
play
you know this is the china if china
takes taiwan
what they do if you go take a look at
global supply chain management that just
kicks them up a whole other notch
because
taiwan punches above its weight
at an astronomical level in the global
supply chain
as a manufacturing partner especially in
semi
so if they take taiwan
they now just which they believe going
back to
chiang kai-shek and you know sending him
um you know on the exile and all those
things that happened
this is a market share and a
uh legacy ownership so part of them
is hey this is legacy ownership this is
our land this is our
province this is our place i mean let's
let's uh
it's kind of like a west berlin thing
let's take down the wall this is ours
all
the all the way but the other side of it
they think the long game economically
this is a play for market share and
control
over the west of manufacturing
listen all i will say about this all
right they're on youtube right now if
you're listening to this
all right after this is done look up
my life my china i am a
communist party member just go into your
bar after this is over and check
chinese communist party member and watch
those videos
and you tell me if that is the future
that you want
that's all that's all i can say all i
can say everything tom said
is great everything that we talk about
here is fine guys
you have to understand what is going on
on a global scale you have to understand
who is pulling the strings who is
pulling the levers you have to
understand
who xi jinping is and what his goals are
all right and part of what we are
looking for in the future
if you don't understand what we talked
about on tuesday when we're talking
about a social score
if you don't understand all right and
you want an actual
human element that goes beyond the
politics and the economics and
the high-level concepts that we talk
about here and you just want to
see for yourself what loss of anonymity
looks like what loss of
agency looks like search chinese
communist party member and watch those
videos that's
that's all i'll say so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you